moi j'ai proposé je proposais de
supprimer 200 me à 300 mille postes de
fonctionnaires et jeudi à françois
effectivement que son chiffre de 600
milles n'est pas vrai je peux mecs du
parc pas exclusivement à te poser la
question jusqu'au bout voilà donc parti
de 600 mines
aujourd'hui tu es à 500000 très bien
l'admettre on voit ses volumes
ensuite cela parlait de 500 mille
fonctionnaires et c'est écrit dans un
texte que je n'ai pas apporté ici mais
que je le pourrai te transmettre si tu
veux maintenant tu parles des emplois
publics y compris les emplois de
contractuels
or on sait très bien qu'un emploi
contractuel donnant ça va être un peu
compliqué pardon de s'expliquer là
dessus un emploi contractuel d'or il
peut être renouvelé donc ce que je dis
c'est que le potentiel de départ à la
retraite dans la fonction publique dans
les cinq ans qui viennent
ses 570 mille personnes environ et donc
si on supprime 500 mille postes
ça veut dire qu'on ne recrutera aucune
infirmière aucun policier aucun
enseignant aurait cependant et je
termine ma question si vous me le
permettez je sais que françois va me
répondre
pendant cette période et ça c'est tout
juste pas possible dans aucune
entreprise dans un pub d'administration
parce que là c'est la sclérose a assuré
voilà et je vais qu'il agrée très
attentif aux arguments juppé c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis candidat
parce que on pose le problème à l'envers
la question qui est posée c'est est ce
qu'on peut continuer à dépenser autant
d'argent et à les emprunter tous les
jours sur les marchés à cinq ans ou à 10
ans pour payer les salaires des
personnels des fonctions publiques ça
c'est apparemment cela doit être posée
réponse donc si on veut répondre à cette
question il faut réduire le nombre
d'emplois publics pourquoi j'ai parlé de
cinq cent mille emplois publics
parce que je propose et c'est bien le
sujet personne ne veut aborder je
propose une augmentation du temps de
travail de l'ensemble des fonctionnaires
et le passage de 35 à 39 heures pour les
5 millions et demi d'emplois publics
ça représente la possibilité de réduire
de 500 milles les emplois publics
les fonctionnaires et les contractuels